Magic, killer clowns, and the actual grim
reaper?
The ending of "Twisted Metal" hinted at a
lot of possibilities.
Here's what might be coming down the road
in a possible second season.
John Doe is a "milkman," essentially an extremely
skilled driver with a souped-up and weaponized
car, who couriers goods, such as medicine,
food, and other supplies, across the post-apocalyptic
world of the "Divided States of America."
John also has amnesia, with only a burnt photo
of him as a kid to link him to his past.
It's eventually revealed in Episode 3 that
the world ended in the year 2002 after a Y2K-type
event decimated everything all over the world.
Walled cities were constructed to protect
the affluent from the dangerous outside world
of scavenging and violence.
One such city is New San Francisco — run
by the power-hungry mayor Raven — a place
John does milkman runs for.
The story of "Twisted Metal" gets going when
Raven offers John a job he can't pass up.
"If you go to New Chicago and bring this package
back for me, I will make you a citizen of
New San Francisco."
"I get to live here?"
John has ten days to complete his mission,
but things get complicated when he gets carjacked
by Quiet.
She's a fugitive on the run from Agent Stone,
who leads a dangerous gang of would-be police officers.
While John and Quiet are antagonistic towards
each other at first, they eventually learn
to work together, and even fall in love, over
the course of their violent road trip.
At the end of "Twisted Metal," John Doe completes
Raven's mission and delivers the package from
New Chicago to New San Francisco at the last
minute.
He's looking forward to having a safe place
to live behind the city walls, but his new
partner throws a wrench in the plan.
Quiet isn't allowed inside.
"We had a deal, John.
You and me."
"And she's with me, that's all you need to
know."
Before John has the chance to reject the offer
of salvation in New San Francisco to stay
with Quiet, she shoots him.
The violent act is done out of love so John
can be taken into medical care by the NSF medics.
John is content in NSF for a while, but he
becomes bored by the repetitive routine of
the suburban-like existence of the walled-in
city.
When he tells Raven his plans to leave NSF
and find Quiet, she tries to convince him
to stay by revealing his family was from Old
San Francisco before the apocalypse.
John still insists on leaving, but Raven doesn't
take the rejection well.
It's at this point that she reveals her real
plan: she sent John out to test his driving
before forcing him to represent her in an
upcoming contest.
Before Quiet joined John on his mission, she
had a quest of her own.
At the beginning of the season, Quiet's brother
Loud kills himself rather than let his sister
die at the hands of Agent Stone, the leader
of a gang of cops trying to "restore order"
in the post-apocalyptic Divided States of
America.
However, rather than restoring order, they
spread terror, violence, and fear, including
turning the DMV into a Guantanamo Bay-esque
torture black site.
Though she helps John on his drive, Quiet
never stops hunting for Stone, and John's
involvement complicates things.
The loss of Quiet's brother left her hopeless
and with a death wish, but John's friendship,
and later love, make her realize that she
could find new connections.
In the end, instead of killing Stone in cold
blood after beating him in car combat, she
decides to wash her hands of him and move
on to heal.
After she leaves John, Quiet, going by the
codename "Roadkill," becomes a liberator of
the wasteland.
She steals and hijacks supplies from wayward
milkmen to give back to the homeless and needy
in a Robin Hood sort of way.
Eventually, though, she's caught by the Dollface
gang whose leader turns out to be John's long-lost sister.
While not one of the main characters, Stu
is still important in the "Twisted Metal" series.
He and his friend Mike are based on the characters
in "Twisted Metal 2" who drive the monster
truck Hammerhead, which sadly doesn't make
an appearance this season.
In the show, rather than being metalhead stoners
who wish for the ability to fly, Mike and
Stu are wayward scavengers, about to be eaten
by cannibals before being saved by Agent Stone's goons.
Stone then offers Mike and Stu the opportunity
to be law-bringers like them.
Stu, however, realizes very quickly that he's
not cruel enough to be a law-bringer, and
Mike eventually sells him out.
Luckily, before Stu is executed, he's rescued
by Sweet Tooth.
The evil clown takes a quick liking to Stu,
partially due to them being big dudes whose
first names start with "s."
Unfortunately, while Sweet Tooth is supportive
of Stu, he's also psychotic and manipulative,
and at one point during the final battle against
Stone kills some allies with no remorse.
"There are no sides, Stubert.
Everybody burns."
When Sweet Tooth forces Stu to kill Mike,
Stu refuses, standing up for himself, and
shooting Sweet Tooth in the eye.
Fans of the game will recognize that this
gives the clown his iconic video game injury
from "Twisted Metal: Black."
Like so much television and film these days,
there is, of course, an after credits scene
following the ending of the "Twisted Metal"
finale.
We see Mike and Stu enjoying their time together
on a secluded beach with their "girlfriends,"
but they're interrupted by an unexpected visitor.
"Good evening!"
"Oh, s—!"
"Actually, I have a better idea."
Mike and Stu share a nervous laugh with Sweet
Tooth, but they're terrified — after all,
the last time they saw the violent clown,
they hit him with their van.
Unfortunately for them, Sweet Tooth stops
laughing, takes out a machete, and stabs Mike
to death.
Afterward, Sweet Tooth drags Stu away screaming.
Is Mike actually dead?
If so, does it end the potential of seeing
Mike and Stu drive a monster truck together?
While that could indeed be true, the whole
thing could be a fake-out.
Maybe Mike survives his wounds, or maybe it's
the setup to an elaborate joke.
It would definitely be nice to see Mike return
— it would be a pretty big disappointment
to see Hammerhead on screen without both Mike
and Stu behind the wheel.
The "Twisted Metal" series isn't subtle about
its anti-capitalist nature.
It shows the great disparity between the haves
and have-nots in the new post-apocalyptic
society, and how those in power will always
continue to amass more wealth and resources
by exploiting those in poverty.
This is made pretty clear by the walled-in
cities of New San Francisco or New Chicago.
In these cities, a small minority of affluent
people live in opulence and luxury, while
the majority of the world lives in poverty
and squalor.
However, the critique goes beyond that.
Consider Quiet's backstory set in the walled
city of Orange County.
After the end of the world, the OC became
a fascistic nightmare, where white upper-middle
class and suburban-coded denizens keep marginalized
and minority workers as slaves.
Though not a true reflection of the actual
place, there is no question that our world
has a long and sad history of subjugating
citizens for the benefit of a few wealthy
and powerful people.
Another important message of "Twisted Metal"
is the necessity of human connections, bonds,
and community.
In capitalism, everything is set up as a competition,
and relationships within that system are meant
to be seen as transactional.
Even personal friendships under capitalism
are often viewed as merely stepping stones
for people to network and elevate their careers
— always at the expense of others.
We see how this manifests at the beginning
of the show, when John Doe's only friend is
his car, Evelyn.
The same goes for Quiet, who isolates herself
from human connection by not even speaking.
They both work alone in their own little toxic
bubbles — and even when they're forced together
due to unforeseen circumstances, they still
try to find ways to undermine or exploit each
other at every opportunity.
Once they decide to actually open up to each
other and work together as a team, they start
to actually succeed in ways they couldn't
have if they were alone.
They even find love and a bond that their
isolation denied them.
It's this connection to others that even leads
to Quiet becoming a liberator for the people
of the wasteland: she is attempting to foster
communities by providing them basic necessities
denied by their world.
In an interview with SyFy, Samoa Joe said
he hopes that the second season gets to be
more violent and dark.
In the first season of "Twisted Metal," Sweet
Tooth is far less bloodthirsty and evil than
he is in the games.
He is indeed violent and psychotic, but there's
a silliness to Joe and Will Arnett's portrayal
of the evil clown that's absent from the games.
This is especially true for the later games
on which the show is based.
In an interview with Deadline, Anthony Mackie
said,
"[John]'s going to have some challenges that's
gonna come his way that's gonna force his
hand to be more of an adult and make some
really tough decisions because you can't be
a milkman all your life."
It seems that there are going to be many morally
gray moments in Season 2 if it indeed happens.
If Twister, Quiet, or even his sister Dollface
joins the tournament, and it's "kill or be
killed," how do you make the right choice
of who lives or dies?
One of the most exciting aspects of the ending
of "Twisted Metal" season one is the fact
that it actually introduces the Twisted Metal
contest into the story.
Much like the 2021 "Mortal Kombat" movie,
the 2023 "Twisted Metal" streaming series
doesn't even introduce the main event that
the whole thing is named after — we'll just
have to wait for more episodes to continue
the story.
To hold over die-hard fans, there are glimpses
of other drivers from the game — including
fan-favorites Mr. Grimm and Axel.
They also imply that other drivers from the
game who showed up earlier in the series — like
Twister, Preacher, and Flower Power — will
be joining the Twisted Metal tournament as well.
Raven is a playable character in the 2001
game "Twisted Metal: Black" — and while
the two characters have nothing in common,
it's certainly possible that we could see
the show's version behind the wheel.
Finally, there's also the possibility that
Agent Stone survived the finale — after
all, we don't see him die on-screen.
Could his character be joining the tournament
also?
We'll just have to wait and see.
Another exciting thing about the end of Season
1 is that it could also lead to the introduction
of the supernatural elements that exist in
the game.
While John and Quiet hear Calypso's voice
while picking up Raven's package in New Chicago,
he's not really mentioned in the show outside
of some shots of graffiti saying "Calypso
is Real" and such.
However, in the games, Calypso is the one
who runs the Twisted Metal tournament in nearly
every entry, and he has magical powers that
grant any wish the winner of the tournament
desires — though the wish usually backfires
in a Monkey's Paw sort of way.
In the finale, once Raven forces John at gunpoint
to be her driver in the Twisted Metal tournament,
she hints at a big reward.
"I need you to win, because Calypso is offering
quite the prize.
The winner gets their heart's desire.
Their greatest wish come true."
This might mean that Calypso has magic powers
in the show as well.
This also means that Mr. Grimm — who is
briefly seen in one of the photos during the
montage of contestants — could be the actual
Grim Reaper like he was in the first two games.
He's been human in other games, but the Reaper
version is still a fan favorite.